how's that what about the Pride Parade
we did you celebrate did you go to
Dallas pride now no I didn't I don't
think I don't think I think they might
have banned it in Dallas I don't know
they're like oh you don't go to the
Pride Parade you didn't go to the proper
a been a pride advance it before the
pride comedy shows yeah I'm sober it
seems like an environment that's fueled
with drugs and alcohol I don't know if
but I'm guessing I drove through the
Pride Parade once in West Hollywood
there's a lot of gay people obviously
West Hollywood but I also sensed a lot
of guys there were just straight dudes
trying to capitalize on it's also like
can I just suck dick in my room what can
I be that kind of gay where I suck dick
in my room is that part of it anymore
yeah is sex even part of it right he's
[ __ ] does somebody have the same
gender even part of it right or do I
have to wrap myself in a cloak and dance
around like and say these people have
the people pride aren't even [ __ ]
right they're not even gay like you said
yeah it's also happening in places where
it's like yeah we're okay with gay
people do the Pride Parade in Birmingham
Alabama really make a change or
something like the tie Rivera's high
Rivera is a very funny guy who performs
all over the country yeah and he goes
into places they're hostile together
yeah I used to do and he's bad [ __ ]
balls
and he goes out and he takes his jokes
and he says here people that might not
accept my lifestyle you're gonna find me
[ __ ] funny and I'm not lecturing you
and I'm not gonna moralize but I bet you
leave here with more respect for gay
people because one of them just [ __ ]
entertain you for an hour
all right so of course the industry
doesn't give a [ __ ] about him okay yeah
they like the people that are dancing
around in West Hollywood I have a child
nobody cats in West Hollywood effects
nobody is impressed performing in New
York in LA some straight men here are
gays and me yeah yeah do you know how
many straight man I could rape Jay they
wouldn't even say anything yeah they
would just sit there me like okay the
hot women are with them they don't to
deal with them they never touch them
they're right it's harder to go into
places where they don't like gay people
listen here's also the problem why is
there a tenure
all dancing aunt this kid Desmond Lee
amazing have you seen this no there's a
ten-year-old kid or a left and he's
dancing on a bar he's at one of the drag
kids and he's dancing on a bar and the
people are throwing money in him and
listen man this is not good
and I've talked to a lot of gay people
who are older and people are like what
the [ __ ] is going on that's not and by
the way it's the same gay people that
are like why are there 400 Chandhok cuz
you got to realize at a certain point a
lot of the transient and gay [ __ ]
but bat bat heads right because I'm
attracted to dude so if you're a woman
and go I'm a dude I'm it's still not
working it doesn't matter right it's
like if you're attracted to really hot
guys and I tell you I'm thin I identify
his thin I identify as a volleyball
champion right people go I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah because I see what I see it's
real yeah so to me the sexual it's just
weird
it's kid it's just some no there there's
something deeply wrong
oh no he said he was he said he's a girl
for a few weeks in a row so we had to do
have no proper measures and get him
woman therapy if your kid has gender
problems number one iiiii say empathize
to an extent with being different but
here's the deal you cannot inject kids
with [ __ ] hormones before there are
18 you're looks this is child abuse
literally it is and in reality is you
cannot have a kid on a [ __ ] bar
that's a alcohol you're allowed in bars
in a sexual way and does he even know
what sex is for money then because
there's a lot of guys and I talked to
her in the closet yeah and will probably
remain so because they don't they're
like I don't want to co-sign this right
and I don't want to co-sign it either
right I'm like what the [ __ ] I wake up
some days and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on right why is there a
ten-year-old kid on a bar dancing who is
okay with this who are this kid's
parents right and then everybody
celebrating is on Good Morning America
like this right now I'm not against if
you if that kid wants to be in a dance
class and you have a boy that wants to
dance with up to it let him into ballet
classes and they don't find out he's gay
when he's 6 my parents put me in dance
classes because I was a professional
[ __ ] actor by the way and it was part
of what I did
and I danced around right it's fine
that's not a thing the problem is being
in a bar and having dudes throw money at
you is is sick and and I don't know why
and there's a lot of people gay straight
and otherwise you know kind of
uncomfortable with this [ __ ] yeah yeah
and it kind of hurts all the progress
that you guys just made just to be
allowed to be gay it's it's a it's a
problem and when you try to have
discussions with people they go oh
you're self-hating gay guy or you're
there so you're that or you're not
really gay or you don't really I did you
don't get it I'm like no no no I get it
what I also get is that this really sets
any movement back because people are
looking at this [ __ ] and they're going
this is [ __ ] wild
yeah and it's wrong it is and this fort
is gonna be drugged out by the time he's
14 or 15 years old and I just don't and
so that it becomes a problem and I have
no issue you can you know pride events
are great and people bin Lizzy if you
want to wear a g-string and do all that
stuff that's not every gay guy and the
media loves that it thinks it is and
everybody likes it it is and there's all
these gay guys it'll go out be like well
if you don't embrace that then you're
not really gay and it's crazy really
crazy it's like telling somebody that
like if they don't conform to every
stereotype they're not really above you
know you're not a black guy you know you
play ball rapper yeah you're not black
like wait a minute you know yeah it
becomes a problem and it's like it's
hard to have these conversations with
people right because you get accused of
all these things but it's like no this
is not okay this is a [ __ ] problem
the kids just that's I when I was a kid
I wanted to be a cowboy I was obsessed
with John Wayne movies loved cowboys
imagine if my parents were like well we
have to respect this and they took me to
the desert put me on a horse and left me
alone I'm sure that is going on
somewhere I'm sure we're been grew up in
Texas that shit's going on there like
our sons a cow bar they give them a real
big line and give them a horse
and then the kid decides the saloon is
the lunchroom at school and he walks in
he kicks open the doors and he goes
guess what I'm wider and then everybody
goes down in a hail of bullets which I
am against I'm against school shootings
and I have said that I have come out and
I said that and I don't know why people
have kind of twisted it and made me
there I've said that I'm against you
after school show you denounced it No